chris i'm ready whenever you are
okay
okay
so
you
self-evicted can you explain to us a
little bit like why you did that what
was sort of the thought process behind
that
um well i really um i really just um
uh it was really family issues i i
really miss my family
and there were some issues going on with
my family i left with my stepdad being
sick
and
there as you know uh my uh
i guess you know the rules of the game
you're not allowed to have any outside
contact with the world
and uh for the whole time that you're in
there it's part of the rules it's just
the rules of the game and i was having a
difficult time with that rule of not
being able to have any contact
um
and uh so
you know i i wanted to stay
and
certainly the house wanted me to stay
the guests
of the house wanted me to say which was
great you know i love that
but i wanted
i really wanted to go because of that
you know
um
you know i was having a great time with
these guys
uh it was such a fun experience playing
the games and
and making friends i meet some of the
greatest friends for life there you know
lamar and
carson and of course carson's cakes
will always be very close to me
and now i know why i kept making cakes i
was like what kind of cake is this he's
like it's peanut butter frosting on
chocolate so i was like okay i guess
i'll eat that at 4 a.m tonight when i'm
sleepwalking
uh but i had no idea that became a thing
until you're on the outside it's amazing
when you're inside you have knows
concept of what's going on
so that need for
outside what's going on is just so
prevalent and important to you
because you can get really
claustrophobic in there um
you know and uh so just yeah in general
being cut off in the outside world and
communicating with that it's very
difficult for me as a person and it kind
of got to me so
um but now everything with the family is
okay thank goodness and uh you know
stabilize and i'm very grateful to say
that
no it's okay you know but um
you know it's just interesting you know
because nobody in there right now still
knows who won the super bowl
isn't that crazy they don't know they're
not allowed to know
what i left with what i'm happy about it
is that
even though i left without having to get
kicked off to leave
or winning
um
those are the two choices but
everybody
seemed to really like me and um
and i left on i would say a high note
for sure and i left with what i would
say integrity
and
some class and definitely self-love and
self-respect
and i knew that
i had
the some amazing relationships with
these guys
and i wanted to keep those i think in
ways the relationships with those guys
in there was more important than winning
a game in a way you know i really did
um and i know those people like carson
and his cakes will always live on
and uh
you know i i can't wait to go see misha
she's already inviting me to our
kickboxing camp you know
game in may and uh
you know and carson and i want to do a
talk show and i think you know lamar and
todd bridges i want to do i want to
produce a
you know some sort of a
uh
some sort of a podcast because they're
so funny
because they sleep right next to each
other todd bridges is the worst snoring
problem i've ever heard in my life and
that that i'm very full to be away from
does it like
i don't know if the show said that but
he does sound like an elephant going in
heat
like i don't know what's happening with
his throat he needs sleep apnea and i
brought it up to him he got so defensive
and angry i was like okay just i can't
even talk
anyway but
i'm glad everything's on the outside
world i'm glad i got to see the rams
when
uh
you know and now i'm out uh in
shreveport i'm in springfield amer uh
springfield illinois right now visiting
my girlfriend of all
places um
you know so that's my valentine's that's
what i'm doing for valentine's day
um as well but uh yeah i had a terrific
time i really did and uh
you know but being cut out cut off from
the outside world is harder than you
think
you think it's okay but
it's it's not you know they it it is a
beautiful place that you're in even
though you have to clean up yourself
uh
laundry and you have to do
there's only one bathroom
um two showers it can get a little
inconvenient but we're all respectful of
each other
but people like cynthia and even teddy
and mariah especially and then
you know lamar and and carson you know i
i made friends for life
and uh
you know that that that's something i
can't you can't get anywhere
well um i think one of the relate like
friendships that people were surprised
by the most but also enjoyed was you and
mariah's uh yeah
um have you had it i know she wanted to
talk to you like uh when you know once
you got out have you guys had a chance
to talk yet or she texted me we texted
each other
and you know she
at least she told me in there that i
really understood where she was coming
from
and she was having a difficult time too
um
she may be very competitive but she's
competitive with games
she didn't know how to do the alliance
games because you know that kind of a
game is psychological and it is kind of
it's a different kind of game and it's
not necessarily the healthiest game
yet it is a game and she had a difficult
time with that i too had a difficult
time with that because i'm not exactly
that kind of person i came on this show
wanting to have a great fun time a light
you know silly fun time and um
and i still did but um
you know um
it was uh
yeah so we'll s
you know i i i will be friendship
friends with her for life yeah for sure
but i told her i was there for her i'd
be there for her
and there are many times that she came
and cried on my shoulder and i was there
for her and
she's such a sweetheart and uh i'm just
glad i made friends for life you know
uh but i i wanted to leave with
integrity and and class and still keep
my
relationships with
them going and uh make cbs happy
because they were so good to me cbs and
um
and uh i just uh wanted everyone to be
happy but uh there was personal problems
going on in the outside world
uh with my family and having no
communication outside is very difficult
as much as it seems like it might be
easy for a while
having cameras on you 24 7 even when
you're sleeping
i mean it's almost like a
virtual prison in a way
but uh not to that extent but it is
fascinatingly
you know almost truman show meets hunger
games in very many ways
you know
it it really is but uh again made
friends for life
and uh
yeah i i can't wait to see them when
they come out
you know i really can't
um of those who are left who would you
like to see do really well in the in the
game
well i think they're all doing really
well
i wish secretly i wish lamar would win
he's not going to win i don't think but
because he's not dying to win so much it
takes a lot of wine it went really badly
todrick wants to win more than anyone
um
i think it's going to come down to
carson or lamar carson or niche
or
um
todrick
a carson yeah me stratography i think
i'll be the three they'll come down to
you i think um
cynthia's got such a big heart though i
mean they're all wonderful
is like like a mother sister figure to
me like she's just like
god what a wonderful person so
she could potentially win too she might
be the most liked
um
but i know i was doing really well i
didn't know i was doing as well as i
thought until i came out people were
like you were like probably gonna win i
was like what why would you say that
like that people loved you like i had no
idea because you have no concept until
you come out
that's what i wanted to ask you that's
uh my last question is you know
obviously we your gameplay may have not
been the best but
you had i mean fans really enjoyed like
your
little one-liners and your comedy and
it's what has that reaction been like
from the fans
um it's all been very very positive like
extremely positive
and um i think the game plan i kind of
gave my opportunity
to say something
to say something for mariah's sake and i
think it was so important for her to
want to leave to stay
she wanted to stay so bad she didn't
know how to play the game exactly in the
sense of
um
she she just didn't know i mean she's
worldly she's an olympic figure skater
she's not a person that's lived in los
angeles and
for since she was a baby
so she's not like la educated she's
worldly so that's a different kind of an
education uh and she um
she's just uh i i thought saying
something like that was important uh for
her because i really cared about her
there are many nights that she was
crying and i consoled her and i i held
her and
and she became a good friend but i was
like you know there for her and she
would say oh chris you're the only one
that understands me
and you know so i uh took that roll on
for her and i
that night of eviction uh when we were
both on the block i i said i'd like for
you to consider her staying here
as opposed to me fighting for myself to
stay there because i already felt like i
was getting a lot of love from everybody
and she felt like she wasn't and i
wanted to express that she wanted that
love
and they give her that chance
you